non nous ne nous trouvons pas en italie
mais boulevard saint-michel très
exactement dans la cave de la librairie
73 où les marionnettes siciliennes nous
donne une représentation de la vraie
histoire de charlemagne et de ses
paladin charlemagne
c'est un grand souvenir pour vous france
gall très bon mais très lointain aussi
je la tire quand vous aviez choisi cette
première chanson en somme qui a été
votre premier succès surtout pensiez
vous à la réussite de charlemagne
c'est à dire que non j'étais très très
content parce que c'était une chanson
d'enfants et puis mes musiciens fallait
personnes qui m'entouraient me dire mais
qu'est ce que pourquoi tu fais cette
chanson ça tu as tu ridiculiser c'est
grotesque que ne fait pas cette chanson
qui fait qu'au bout d'une semaine là sur
mon disque était sorti j'ai téléphoné il
devait être en 4 heures du matin voilà
passage et je lui ai dit je vous en
supplie arrêter la sortie du disque je
ne veux pas que ce disque sort du le
pacha le charlemagne sorte parlons d'une
marionnette que vous avez rendu célèbre
france gall puisqu'elle a été traduit
dans toutes les langues
la poupée de cire poupée de son elles
étaient traduites fin par mois en 5 4
langues allemand italien anglais et
japonais et où vous la chantier dans ces
langues là vous parlez ce langues
non je parle pas mais eux j'apprends le
japonais je la prenais parfois
phonétique
mais sinon je connais un petit peu
l'anglais et puis j'ai fait trois en
allemand au lycée et en amérique on l'a
chanté en français je crois oui je sais
je ne sais pas je crois pas je ne sais
pas peut-être qu'elles étaient
enregistrés par quelqu'un d'autre
en amérique un je ne sais pas vous venez
de choisir une nouvelle chanson
marionnettes également polichinelle est
ce que c'est pour garder votre public
d'enfants car je sais que votre public
est très jeune n'est ce pas c'est à dire
que pour ce disque là j'aurais voulu
avoir un disque plus adulte t on au jeu
j'aurai un petit peu touché les
personnes un petit peu plus âgés sans
pour cela a laissé tomber mais mon
public jeune enfin je voulais faire un
disque du pliage et en définitive